this is where it gets crazy ladies and
gentlemen director of black voices for
Trump is held in jail without bond
Harrison Floyd becomes the first Maga
Ally to be booked behind bars in the
Georgia election fraud case no bond
they're starting light I think they're
not locking everybody up because they're
they're slow rolling it they know they
can't shock the system but yo this story
is crazy look at this he says apparently
FBI went to his house to serve him and
he said who the f Do You Think You Are
Floyd allegedly screamed the affidavit
says describing that Floyd was standing
chest to chest with the agent after
knocking him back with his body in
Georgia Floyd is accused
alongside Steven cliffguard Lee a police
chaplain and trevian cootie Kanye West's
former publicist of pressuring poll
worker Ruby Freeman into falsely saying
she committed election fraud Freeman and
her daughter Shea Moss who gave tearful
testimony to the house select committee
January 6 were subjects of a conspiracy
theory echoed by Trump and his allies
this is the crazy thing did these people
genuinely believe she committed fraud
and they were going to her being like
what did you do we saw videos is that a
criminal act
and now I got quite I don't trust the
government
apparently they're saying that he
assaulted an FBI agent he was charged
with attacking an FBI agent well I
strongly recommend you don't do that who
was working with special on special
counsel Jack Smith's parallel probe in
2020 election appearance by Trump and
his allies The Washington Post reported
Wednesday and affidavit says Floyd Body
slammed an agent who arrived at his
Rockville Maryland home to subpoena him
before a Federal grand jury in
Washington D.C so my question is
what is he being charged with in Georgia
right held without bond in Georgia he
was charged with racket's hearing
conspiracy solicit false statements and
influencing Witnesses so the FBI thinks
a totally different case he's being
charged very similar to many many of
these other defendants and they're not
letting him out
things are getting crazy ladies and
gentlemen the krasensteins you gotta
love them they have no limit
they will feign reasonableness and then
they're like I agree with the charges
against Trump's lawyers for the simple
fact they provided him legal counsel and
it's just like I'm like dude you guys
have to have a limit right like what is
it they're going to start rounding
people up onto trains and the Crescent
scenes are going to be like well now
hold on we don't know exactly why
they're rounding people up let's give
them the benefit of the doubt dude they
are arrest Jenna Ellis is being
criminally charged under Rico for simply
being Trump's lawyer that's it she
didn't do anything else that's it part
of a conspiracy insane
think about it at work so because now
everybody's going to be afraid to
represent Trump or any uh Republican
figure or anybody else so it's effective
which is exactly which goes back to my
point that I was making before you know
I really think this is about
intimidation I said this you know a
couple nights ago too The Establishment
as in when I say The Establishment I
mean the bureaucracy it's in DC and
likely the Democrat Party and their
allies in the media they don't want
people to defend Trump they want people
to be afraid to associate with Trump the
Trump statement is up let's play the
video it's only one minute long ladies
and gentlemen here it is
they did very well to have him just walk
up so
you challenge an election I thought the
election was a rigged election the
stolen election and I should have every
right to do that as you know you have
many people that you've been watching
over the years through the same thing
whether it's Hillary Clinton or Stacy
Abrams or many others
when you uh have that great freedom to
challenge you have to be able to
otherwise you get a very dishonest
elections what has taken place here is
the travesty of Justice we did nothing
wrong I did nothing wrong and everybody
knows it I've never had such support and
that goes with the other ones too what
they're doing is election interference
they're trying to interfere with an
election there's never been anything
like it in our country before this is
their way of campaigning and this is one
instance but you have three other
instances it's election interference
yeah I agree and my question is this if
the Democrats are campaigning As Trump
said off of this and they are this uh
this Fulton D.A launched a fundraiser
then Republicans will have no choice but
to campaign on the exact same issue in
the other direction and if the Democrats
are saying vote for us and we will
imprison anyone you hate and the Trump
supporters are saying we will get
revenge and go after those who are
weaponizing the legal system where where
does this end it doesn't it's like a
South Korea from lender sand
um the last several leaders have all
been in prison so it's like as soon as
the next party gets in the last party
guy gets locked up yeah and it sounds
like Illinois yeah
oh yeah yeah
but I don't think it ends with with just
getting locked up the Democrats are
saying we will crush you the Republicans
mostly sitting on their hands but if a
Tit for Tat does arise
if Trump gets reelected
the Revenge will not just be on the Deep
state for everything they did during his
first term it's going to be on everyone
right now for everything they're doing
yeah I feel like Camp's gonna have a
really hard time when Trump gets elected
he'll be federally indicted how could he
not if Trump gets uh here's my
prediction if Trump gets reelected
election fraud charges across the board
and tons of Governors face maybe not
tons of maybe a handful we're probably
going to see a bunch of democrat
officials I imagine they'll be charged
if Trump wins I cannot imagine a man so
obsessed with 2020 does not remain
obsessed with 2020 and then as we've
already seen you can indict a ham
sandwich oh yeah so the people were like
there's no evidence Trump wouldn't be
able to do it yeah that's not an issue
if Trump gets in and he gets a an AG
that is totally on board you're gonna
see whatever they need pop up and there
will be charges
assume that this makes
even more appealing to people who are
generally critical of the Criminal
Justice System right like people who
feel like it's corrupted already for
non-political reasons are looking at
what's happening to Trump and saying uh
yeah so he's experienced it too none of
us are safe he is I in some ways
becoming more of a a candidate for
people I would assume would typically
vote for the Democratic party because
they're always saying we'll fix this and
Republicans are trying to lock you up
yeah exactly I I'm I do not share your
optimism about new voter new Trump
voters but um that being said one of the
things that I noticed that I really
liked that he said he said I believed it
was a rigged election and it was that
kind of uh verbiage articulating it
properly really really really really
really really matters because they're
going to have to try to convince the
jury that he believed that he lost and
that he believed that it was a fair loss
and he knew he was violating the law
they have to prove to a jury that what
he what he believed they've approved
what was in his head and the only person
that can screw that up is Donald Trump
yeah you know his lawyers were like oh
my goodness thank goodness he said it
the right way he there's no ad-lib here
because it he's already got oh he's
already loaded against him he's got a
bunch of a bunch of things stacked
against him in the when it comes to
people Prosecuting himself and if he's
not minding his p's and q's he can put
himself in significant into a
significant problem well I hope that
when when Trump wins reelection assuming
he does
as he begins
instructing the AG to go after people we
get a really cool Montage with like
Staying Alive by the Bee Gees instead
having sunglasses putting them on and
then there's like a montage of like
indicted indicted Trump should have
indicted people in his first term Trump
should have launched investigations when
they were investigating him for Russia
gate he should have immediately said we
are going to investigate the lies Trump
should have countered immediately and
I'm not I'm not ragging on him for not
not knowing at the future I'm saying
hindsight is 20 20. Trump could have
said my fellow Americans
currently there are political partisans
that are accusing the highest office in
this country of being subservient to
Vladimir Putin and the Russians this is
sedition This Is A Lie the American
people have spoken
so we will be bolstering the
investigation into these claims but
making sure it is holistic and covers
all ground and we figure out who is
pushing the narrative and why he could
have said yeah yeah I'm on board here's
my guy joining in and then gone after
democrats for the Steele dossier for
instance why did it take so long for us
to figure out that Hillary Clinton was
the one backing that stuff
well I needed people to tell him to do
that because keep in mind he was not a
politician if Tucker Carlson had just
said it one time
Tucker you know then Trump would have
been like you know I was watching Tucker
he says I should investigate I'll do it
and then he would have done it and we
wouldn't be here right now come on
Tucker what are you doing no I mean I
think the there are a lot of things that
I wish Trump had done while he was in
office and obviously we can't go back
um my concern would be that he doesn't
do something going forward so if he's
re-elected I would like to see some kind
of action I mean you were saying before
the show that uh Jim Jordan's
investigation for on Fannie Willis you
felt like maybe he should have called it
earlier oh yeah hello what time is it I
mean how long ago was he charged is
Congress that slow you can't put it
together you can't say hey you know what
Fannie um how about you come up here
Thursday
how about the Thursday the 24th come on
in front of Congress that would have
been beautiful so while Trump is getting
arrested Fannie can be testified in
front of Congress and enjoying her day
in another location
yeah new thought because I assume she's
down there hanging out with all her
friends being like our work is
accomplished good job everybody and she
should be sweating bullets but they're
doing nothing thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time